This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。确定是人类。2%。这是指在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何建立心理坚韧、保持健康以及培养韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”加“percent”，可在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚克斯·英格利士。在每集节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊20世纪80年代那样。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都实在不太安全进行的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的有执照的专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变及其含义的播客。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode, another topic.
关于我们的心理学。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到这个播客。新听众、老听众，无论你身在世界何处。非常高兴你能来到这里，收听另一期节目，探讨另一个话题。
On this lovely Friday, we're going to discuss the concept of milestone anxiety, which is essentially the fear we get that we are not reaching certain life milestones, such as graduating, getting into a relationship, getting a first job, getting engaged, having children, as quick as those around us, and when society expects us to reach these milestones. It's a feeling that I have been struggling with recently, and I know for a fact that I am not alone. So let's talk about it today.
在这个美好的周五，我们要讨论“里程碑焦虑”这个概念，这本质上是指我们的一种恐惧：我们担心自己没有像周围人那样，也没有按照社会期望的时间节点，达到某些人生里程碑，比如毕业、谈恋爱、找到第一份工作、订婚、生子。这是我最近一直在苦苦挣扎的一种感觉，而且我很确定我绝对不是一个人。所以我们今天来聊聊这个。
Malstone anxiety, this phrase, it's actually one that has been around for a while, but it's been repurposed from developmental psychology. It's usually used to describe the anxiety that parents get when their children do not reach certain developmental milestones like walking or speaking when they should be. But when we become adults, a whole new set of societal or developmental milestones arise. And it's not our parents that are fearing for us anymore,
里程碑焦虑，这个词其实已经存在一段时间了，但它是从发展心理学中被借用并赋予了新含义的。它通常用来描述父母在孩子没有在应该学会走路或说话的年龄达到某些发展里程碑时产生的焦虑。但当我们成年后，一系列全新的一套社会或发展里程碑便会出现。而且不再是我们的父母在为我们感到担忧，
although I'm sure they are at times, but it's us. we are the ones who are now in control, we become the primary adult in our lives, and we have to carry that anxiety that perhaps we are falling behind our peers. Milestone anxiety, it becomes a really serious fear and stressor for a lot of us in our 20s. I really wanted to do this episode this week because of a message that I received from one of our listeners who wrote in to me on Instagram about how she had never had a boyfriend. She's 25 and she spoke so candidly about the anxiety that this has caused her, especially as all of her friends are getting engaged or moving in with the people that they're dating. And I really
尽管我确信他们有时确实如此，但这次是我们。是我们开始掌控自己，我们成为了自己生活中的主要成年人，并且我们必须承受那种“我们可能正在落后于同龄人”的焦虑。对于我们许多处于二十多岁的人来说，里程碑焦虑变成了一种非常严重的恐惧和压力源。我之所以非常想做这周的节目，是因为我收到了一位听众在Instagram上发给我的私信，她谈到自己从来没有交过男朋友。她今年25岁，并且非常坦率地谈到了这给她带来的焦虑，尤其是当她所有的朋友都开始订婚或与他们约会对象同居时。我真的
felt for her and so many others who I'm sure are in the same boat in some capacity or another. We put a lot of pressure on ourselves to conform to this societally ingrained timeline of where we should be when. And also to achieve so much at a young age. And I think that's causing a lot of damage to those of us in our 20s because, well, our paths are never going to be the same. And they're definitely not going to be the same as people we see bragging on social media or the same as our parents or older generations. which is where a lot of these expectations originated. I think additionally, happiness doesn't always come from a conventional way of living or doing things the normal way.
对她以及其他许多我确信在某种程度上也处于同样境地的人感同身受。我们给自己施加了很大的压力，要去符合那种社会根深蒂固的时间表，即我们在什么年龄应该处于什么位置。而且还要在年轻时取得巨大的成就。我认为这正在对我们这些二十多岁的人造成很大的伤害，因为，嗯，我们的道路永远不会完全相同。而且它们绝对不会跟我们在社交媒体上看到那些炫耀的人相同，也不会跟我们的父母或长辈相同——很多这些期望正是起源于长辈。我认为除此之外，幸福并不总是来自于一种常规的生活方式或按寻常方式做事。
There are so many people who don't graduate university until they're in their 50s, who don't meet the love of their life until they're 70, who don't get on a plane until they're in their 30s or 40s. And we need to cultivate a greater acceptance of the many different paths people have through life, instead of feeling this intense pressure to be meeting certain milestones at certain points. The thing is, though, we can realize this diversity,
有许多人直到五十多岁才大学毕业，直到七十多岁才遇到挚爱，直到三四十岁才第一次坐飞机。我们需要培养对人们生活中许多不同人生道路的更大包容度，而不是去承受那种在特定时间点必须达成特定里程碑的巨大压力。问题在于，尽管我们可以认识到这种多样性，
we can realize this nuance, and still feel an incredible amount of pressure or anxiety that we are missing out, or we are going too slow, or that we are quote-unquote failures because of the impact of milestone anxiety. So today I want to break down the origins, the causes and the details of this experience, how to push back against this feeling and respect your own journey and your own path through
我们可以认识到这种细微差别，但由于里程碑焦虑的影响，我们仍然会感到巨大的压力或焦虑，觉得自己错过了什么、进度太慢了，或者觉得自己是所谓的“失败者”。所以今天我想剖析这种经历的根源、成因和细节，探讨如何去对抗这种感觉，并尊重你在二十多岁乃至整个人生中属于你自己的旅程和道路。对于我们所有那些觉得自己正在失败、正在落后并错过人生关键里程碑的人，我想提供一些慰藉、
your 20s, but also through life. And for all of us out there who are feeling like we are failing or we are falling behind and missing out on key milestones, I want to provide some solaceous. and some reassurance and some answers for why you're going through this reaction and this experience and also how you can find a way forward and not feel so much pressure and not put so much pressure on yourself to be meeting certain expectations that society, your family and even yourself are putting on you. So for all of you out there who are in this boat with me, this episode is for you. I am so excited and without further ado,
一些安心的话语以及一些答案，告诉你为什么会有这种反应和经历，以及你如何才能找到前进的方向，不再承受如此巨大的压力，也不用强迫自己去迎合社会、家庭甚至你自己强加给你的那些期望。所以，对于所有和我有一样感受的听众，这期节目就是为你准备的。我非常兴奋，闲话少说，
I think we should get into it. One of my major inspirations for this episode was none other than the wonderful Millie Bobby Brown. Yes, the same one from Stranger Things. Recently, she announced that at the age of 19, maybe 20, she was engaged. And I think for those of us between the age of 19 to 30 who are unmarried or single, we all kind of took a bit of a deep breath in and maybe had a bit of a bit of a very bit of freak out as the comparison and the milestone anxiety set in. Because, you know, I'm almost 24 and I am
我想我们应该切入正题了。我做这期节目的主要灵感来源之一，正是了不起的米莉·波比·布朗。是的，就是《怪奇物语》里的那个女孩。最近她宣布，在19岁或20岁的时候，她订婚了。我想对于我们这些年龄在19到30岁之间、尚未结婚或单身的人来说，我们大概都倒吸了一口凉气，并且随着比较和里程碑焦虑的袭来，多多少少都有点被吓到了。因为，你知道，我快24岁了，我
nowhere near dating anyone seriously, let alone getting engaged and then married. And that drop in our stomach is what we're talking about today. The sensation that if there are people out there reaching these massive milestones at that age, we must be doing something wrong. We must be falling behind. And I think that goes hand in hand with a sensation of, will these things ever happen for me? And what happens if they don't? We feel an immense pressure to live up to this intangible but very much real blueprint that society has set out for us around what our lives should look like at a certain age or stage of our life.
离认真跟任何人约会还差得十万八千里，更不用说订婚然后结婚了。胃里那种下坠的感觉正是我们今天要讨论的话题。那种感觉就是：如果有人能在那个年纪达成这些重大的里程碑，那我们一定做错了什么。我们一定是在落后。我认为这与这样一种感觉如影随形：这些事情会发生在我身上吗？如果它们不发生会怎样？我们感到了一种巨大的压力，要去活出社会为我们设定好的那个无形但又非常真实的蓝图，即我们在生活的某个特定年龄或阶段应该过成什么样。
Your friends are getting married. Everyone has a partner bit you or receiving promotions, buying houses. graduating or moving to some faraway city and you're not quite there yet. It can feel really terrible and new research has suggested and shown that the pressure to reach certain milestones that we deem as important is increasingly becoming a very real source of anxiety for those of us in our 20s. Between 77 to 83% of people aged 16 to 39, report feeling some pressure to meet certain milestones, such as getting married or having kids, and they feel incredibly trapped and hopeless when they don't. The fact that this is so common and yet rarely spoken about astounds me. But it also
你的朋友们在结婚。除了你之外每个人都有了伴侣，或者在升职、买房、毕业、搬到某个遥远的城市，而你还没走到那一步。这感觉真的很糟糕，新的研究已经表明，达到我们认为重要的某些里程碑的压力，正日益成为我们二十多岁人群中一种非常真实的焦虑来源。在16至39岁的人群中，有77%到83%的人表示感到了达到某些里程碑（如结婚或生孩子）的压力，并且在未能达成时感到无比的受困和绝望。这种现象如此普遍，却又极少被讨论，这让我感到震惊。但它也
makes a lot of sense why so many of us are feeling this way we're feeling behind in our lives. We have been sold a very traditional idea of what our lives should look like from a young age even if we don't explicitly realize it. It is in every movie we watch in the speeches and the examples given to us by our teachers and our parents, in the people we were told not to be like. it's in the behavior displayed by many of our idols and then as we get older our peers and it goes something like this we graduate high school with good grades we go to college or university we graduate from there we get a good first job great paycheck pick up a partner along the way marriage promotion nice house by 26 or 27 kids by 30 success retirement death that's the way that we were taught it should be
非常合乎情理，解释了为什么我们当中有这么多人会有这种感觉——觉得自己的人生落后了。从很小的时候起，即使我们没有明确意识到，我们就已经被灌输了一种关于生活应该是什么样子的非常传统的观念。它存在于我们看的每一部电影中，存在于我们的老师和父母对我们的演讲和给出的榜样中，存在于我们被告知不要成为的那种人身上；它存在于我们的许多偶像、以及后来的同龄人所表现出的行为中，大致是这样的：我们以优异的成绩高中毕业，我们上大学，我们从大学毕业，我们找到第一份好工作、拿着丰厚的薪水，一路上顺便找个伴侣、结婚、升职、在26或27岁前买套好房子、在30岁前生孩子、成功、退休、死亡。这就是我们被教导的生活应该有的样子。
And within all of those chapters, there are these almost micro milestones that we feel like we have to accomplish by a certain age. And interestingly, I think we all have some implicit sense of what those are and we feel the pressure to reach them, such as dating a long-term partner, you know, 24 to 25, graduating on time before 23, certain saving goals, having savings by 22, having a clear idea. of what we want our career to be as early as 21. Very few of us are going to meet every step of that timeline. And yet we still feel so much pressure to do so. Half of the reason that we feel this implicit pressure is because of the standards that have been set by our parents and the generations before us. I don't think that we could ever really find an origin for some of these expectations.
而在所有这些章节中，都有几乎微型的里程碑，让我们觉得必须在某个特定年龄完成。有趣的是，我认为我们所有人对于这些里程碑都有某种内化的感知，并且感到了达到它们的压力，比如在24到25岁时和长期伴侣约会，在23岁之前按时毕业，设定某些储蓄目标，在22岁时拥有存款，早在21岁时就对自己的职业生涯有清晰的规划。我们当中极少有人能够完全符合那个时间表上的每一步。然而我们仍然感到如此巨大的压力去这么做。我们之所以感到这种内化压力，有一半原因是因为我们的父母以及我们之前的世代所设定的标准。我认为我们可能永远无法真正找到其中一些期望的起源。
expectations. Some of them are biological, like having kids. Others are caused by religious influences, such as getting married at a certain age and, you know, all of these ideas around purity culture. But some of the other milestones that we feel are pressure to reach, they seem to have just emerged one day, out of the blue, as fact. And regardless of where these milestones and these expectations come from, a lot of us do look to our parents or adult figures as a reference point for what we should be doing and how we should be doing it. But in doing so, we kind of forget that a generation ago, things were really different. It was more acceptable to be married by your very early 20s and to have children by 25. It was also an entirely different economic and financial
期望。有些是生物学上的，比如生孩子。有些是由宗教影响引起的，比如在某个特定年龄结婚，以及，你知道，所有这些围绕纯洁文化的观念。但我们觉得有压力去达成的其他一些里程碑，似乎只是某一天突然凭空出现，并变成了既定事实。无论这些里程碑和期望从何而来，我们中的许多人确实把父母或成年长辈作为参考点，来衡量我们应该做什么以及应该怎么做。但在这样做时，我们有点忘记了在一个世代之前，情况真的非常不同。在二十岁出头就结婚、在25岁前生孩子是更被社会接受的。当时也完全处于不同的经济和财务
climate, you could buy property for like a fifth of the price, more or less. You know, you could buy a house on a working salary even, whereas now we don't have so much of that flexibility and that job security and that financial security. Younger generations, I think, like us in our 20s, the people who I'm sure are listening to this, all this research has shown that we are less likely to own our own homes. We are more. likely to have children later in life. The age that women are having their first child has been steadily increasing for decades. I think it's around 31 now, but back in like the 1950s, it was 22. And essentially, we are achieving these ingrained social milestones at an older age than our
环境，你可以用大约五分之一的价格买到房产，大体如此。你甚至可以用一份工薪阶层的薪水买下一栋房子，而现在我们没有那么多灵活性、工作安全感和财务安全感。我认为，像我们这样二十多岁、我确信正在收听这期节目的年轻一代，所有研究都表明我们拥有自己房屋的可能性更小。我们更有可能在晚年才生孩子。女性生第一个孩子的年龄几十年来一直在稳步上升。我想现在大概是31岁，但在20世纪50年代左右，那是22岁。从本质上讲，我们达到这些根深蒂固的社会里程碑的年龄比我们的
parents and even the generation before them. Things are really different now. They're massively different. We are about to enter a pretty huge recession. Our approach to dating is entirely different and so much less organic with the creation of dating apps. But yet we still feel very much tied down to the same blueprint and timeline and we feel anxious when we stray from what we think is conventional. But we're also increasingly out of place. We feel really out of place as we compare ourselves to others and their success and their path through life. There's also the added pressure, I guess, from friends and family asking us when we're going to settle down, when we're going to get a real job, when we're going to have kids. I'm telling you that if one more family member
父母甚至他们的上一代人都要大。现在的情况真的不同了。它们有着巨大的不同。我们正即将进入一场相当严重的经济衰退。随着约会软件的出现，我们的约会方式完全不同了，也少了很多自然感。然而，我们仍然感到被死死地绑在同一个蓝图和时间表上，当我们偏离我们认为的常规时，我们会感到焦虑。但我们也越来越与周围人格格不入。当我们把自己的成功和人生道路与他人进行比较时，我们感到了真正的不合时宜。我想，还有来自朋友和家人的额外压力，他们问我们什么时候安定下来、什么时候找份真正的工作、什么时候生孩子。我告诉你们，如果哪个家庭成员
at Christmas time asked me if I'm dating anyone seriously, I'm going to explode. Because it's not like I'm avoiding it. It's not like I like feeling like I'm in the slow lane compared to everyone else. But that is essentially the crux of what we're talking about today that we feel so much pressure from all of these different sources to be doing things at a certain time. And if we're not doing that, there is all of this stigma and this pressure and this implicit understanding that we are somewhat of a failure. All of this comes down to milestone anxiety that uncomfortable. That uncomfort comfortable feeling in our gut, the nervous thoughts in our brain telling us that we are not on track, that we haven't done enough. So what exactly is it? What is that feeling? I realized I haven't
在圣诞节时再问我是否在认真约会，我就会原地爆炸。因为并不是我在刻意逃避。并不是我喜欢觉得自己比其他所有人都在慢车道上。但这本质上就是我们今天讨论的核心所在——我们从所有这些不同的来源感受到了巨大的压力，被要求在特定的时间做特定的事情。如果我们没有做到这一点，就会伴随着所有的污名化、压力以及那种“我们某种程度上是个失败者”的内化理解。这一切都归结为里程碑焦虑——那种令人不舒服的感觉。我们内心深处的那种不适感，我们大脑中那些告诉我们“我们偏离了轨道、我们做得还不够”的神经质想法。那么这究竟是什么？那种感觉是什么？我意识到我还没有
really given you a definition yet and I want to get into the psychology a little bit further. So milestone anxiety, it's essentially the pressure to reach traditional life milestones by a certain age. It's a very unique anxiety that is often associated with our 20s and even our 30s, where we feel a real crunch period to get to a certain point in our life based on our reflections and what our parents did and what those around us are doing as well. And when we do not meet those milestones, this results in feelings of restlessness, feelings of unease, stress, low confidence. and anxiety. Importantly, it's not a diagnosable anxiety disorder, although some suggest that it does go hand in hand with a generalized anxiety disorder and even depression, but it's really a term that has been coined recently to describe particularly Gen Z and millennials who are feeling this pressure. And it came from a study in 2002 that really attempted to put a name to a fear
真正给出一个定义，我想进一步深入探讨心理学。所以，里程碑焦虑，它本质上是在特定年龄达到传统人生里程碑的压力。这是一种非常独特的焦虑，通常与我们的二十多岁甚至三十多岁相关，在这个时期，基于我们的反思、父母的经历以及周围人的做法，我们感到需要在一个紧迫的时期内达到生活中的某个特定点。而当我们没有达到这些里程碑时，就会导致烦躁、不安、压力、自信心低下和焦虑等情绪。重要的是，它并不是一种可诊断的焦虑症，尽管有人认为它确实与广泛性焦虑症甚至抑郁症并存，但它实际上是最近创造的一个词，用来描述那些感受到这种压力的Z世代和千禧一代。它源于2002年的一项研究，该研究真正试图为一个恐惧赋予一个名称、
and a new face and a new wave of anxiety that were impacting people between the ages of, you know, 20 to their late 30s. All of these therapists, they were reporting that these people, these young people, were coming in with this new experience that they couldn't quite put their finger on, but it was really common and all of these people were reporting the same things. So these researchers, they went out and they tried to find the correct, term and the correct profile to describe what was going on. They did a groundbreaking study. It was conducted a few years back in the UK and essentially it identified that there were these main
一个新的面孔以及新一波影响年龄在20岁到30岁末之间人群的焦虑。所有这些治疗师都在报告说，这些年轻人带着这种崭新的经历来到诊所，他们无法确切指出这是什么，但它非常普遍，所有这些人都在报告同样的事情。因此，这些研究人员走访并试图找到正确术语和正确的档案来描述正在发生的事情。他们做了一项突破性的研究。这是几年前在英国进行的，基本上它确定了16至30岁人群最关心的这些主要里程碑。我想我们很多人都能在个人层面上产生共鸣。生孩子是二十多岁的人感到有压力去达成的头号里程碑，几乎有三分之一的人有同感。
milestones that those between 16 and 30 were most concerned about. And I think a lot of us can relate to these on a personal level. Having children was the number one milestone that people in their 20s felt pressure to reach with almost a third. That's right, a third of us feeling some form of pressure to have children. When I read this, I was actually really surprised because I thought that the main milestone would be marriage or a long-term relationship because partnership does seem to take a precedence over procreation, but no, that's not the case. And when we examine it deeper, I think we do feel this very intrinsic, instinctual pressure to have children, to pass on our genes and to grow the next generation. And that pressure is both external and societal,
没错，我们当中有三分之一的人感到了要生孩子的某种压力。当我读到这个数据时，我其实非常惊讶，因为我原以为主要的里程碑会是结婚或长期恋爱关系，因为伴侣关系似乎比生育优先，但事实并非如此。当我们更深入地审视它时，我认为我们确实感受到了这种非常内在的、本能的压力去生孩子、传递我们的基因并繁衍下一代。这种压力既是外部的和社会的，
but also internal and biological. There is a bit of a deadline to make this happen and deadlines bring dread. It's kind of hard to explain, but I think many of us hit our mid-20s. We start considering fertility. Our frontal lobe kicks into gear. And suddenly we get hit with this vision of what we want from our lives and what we need to do in the next 10 years to get there. And we are so overwhelmed by our expectations and what we want or what we desire that we become paralyzed. I always think of this scene in friends where Rachel turns 30 and she's like, okay, well, I want to have children by 35, which means that I have to be married by 33 because I want to be married by, you know, I want to be married for a couple of years before then, but I want to be engaged
也是内部的和生物学上的。要实现这一点有一个微小的截止期限，而截止期限会带来恐惧。这有点难以解释，但我认为我们很多人到了二十多岁中期。我们开始考虑生育问题。我们的额叶开始发挥作用。突然之间，我们被这样一种愿景击中：我们对生活有什么诉求，以及我们在未来10年里需要做什么才能实现它。我们被自己的期望以及我们想要的或渴望的东西压得喘不过气来，以至于我们瘫痪了。我总是想起《老朋友》里的那个场景，蕾切尔30岁了，她说：“好吧，我希望在35岁之前生孩子，这意味着我必须在33岁之前结婚，因为我想在……”你知道，“我想在那之前结婚几年，但我希望订婚
for at least a year and a half and I want to have known the guy for a year and a half. So that means I need to be doing all these things. I need to be setting this plan up right now. And although that's obviously a fictional representation, it's a TV show, I remember watching that scene and being like, I get it. That makes so much sense to me. That is so relatable. And there are some other major milestones as well that can create the same degree of anxiety.
至少一年半，并且我想了解那个家伙一年半。这意味着我需要做所有这些事情。我需要现在就把这个计划安排好。”尽管这显然是一个虚构的表现，它是一个电视节目，但我记得看那个场景时我想的是：我懂。这对我来说太有道理了。这太有共鸣了。还有一些其他的重大里程碑也能产生同等程度的焦虑。
I mentioned one before, but marriage, relationships, these are a huge source of pressure for us because there is this very repetitive idea and fantasy that love is the point of life. It is the reason for living. So without it, we can feel quite meaningless and like we don't have something that is going to make us whole. Additionally, a big focus of our 20s and our various romantic relationships that we have is the pressure to meet your partner. And we put a lot of pressure on ourselves that if we are not and that if we don't have someone, that we're somehow missing out on these experiences, that somehow there's something wrong with us. We are a failure. Everyone else around us has one.
我之前提到过一个，但结婚、恋爱，这些对我们来说是巨大的压力源，因为存在着这样一种非常重复的理念和幻想：爱是人生的意义。它是活着的理由。因此，没有它，我们会感到毫无意义，仿佛我们缺少了某个能让我们完整的东西。此外，我们二十多岁的很大一部分重心以及我们所经历的各种浪漫关系，都是结识伴侣的压力。我们给自己施加了很大的压力：如果我们没有，如果我们没有某个人，我们就在某种程度上错过了这些经历，某种程度上我们出了问题。我们是个失败者。我们周围的每个人都有一个。
and everyone else around us seems to be meeting the loves of their life seems to be getting engaged and we haven't yet. So what does that say about me? What does that say about us? Another one that I think really deserves mention is going to university, but also things like buying a house, achieving a certain level of career success. All of these are not only inextricably linked to this internalized social narrative, but also what we see others doing, which we know carries an incredible weight because social comparison has such a deep influence on our brain and how we interpret our surroundings. If we see all of these people, particularly those close to us, meeting certain milestones, we inherently look to our own lives and compare.
并且我们周围的每个人似乎都在遇见他们的人生挚爱，似乎都在订婚，而我们还没有。那么这对我说明了什么？这对我们说明了什么？另一个我认为绝对值得一提的是上大学，还有买房、获得一定程度的职业成功等事情。所有这些不仅与这种内化的社会叙事密不可分，也与我们看到其他人正在做的事情息息相关，我们知道这承载着难以置信的重量，因为社会比较对我们的大脑以及我们如何解读周围环境有着深远的影响。如果我们看到所有这些人，尤其是那些与我们亲近的人达到了某些里程碑，我们就会本能地审视自己的生活并进行比较。
And when we come up short, I don't really like to say it like that, but when we see that there is a gap between what other people are doing, what other people are achieving, and what we've done with our lives, we feel really terrible about ourselves. And that compounds to create a lot of anxiety. Interestingly, what I find particularly fascinating about milestone anxiety is that very few of us have not experienced it in some way or another. The research proves that the majority of us between 16 and 30 have at some point felt some pressure, some external force to be doing more and to be meeting these goals sooner and sooner. Yet we often endure our shame and our anxiety in silence. It's a very solitary experience, but its prevalence also
当我们有所不足时——我其实不太喜欢这么说——但当我们看到其他人在做的事情、其他人取得的成就与我们用自己的人生所做的事情之间存在差距时，我们对自己的感觉真的很糟糕。这会复合叠加，产生大量的焦虑。有趣的是，关于里程碑焦虑，我发现特别迷人的一点是，我们中极少有人没有以某种方式经历过它。研究证明，我们16到30岁之间的大多数人在某个时候都感受到过某种压力、某种外部力量，要求我们做更多的事情，并更快更早地达成这些目标。然而，我们经常默默承受着耻辱和焦虑。这是一种非常孤独的经历，但它的普遍性也
shows that most of us are actually not on a conventional path. In some area or another, we are inherently very much worried that we are not meeting the norm. It's very much a shared experience, a shared sensation that is similar for all of us. These are some of the biggest, I would say, indicators or signs of milestone anxiety. If you're listening to this being like, that sounds very, very similar to what I've been going through and to the feelings I've been having. I would like you to listen to these for a second because if you recognize yourself in these, it might be the case that milestone anxiety is something that you're struggling with. First of all, if you are constantly ruminating over the fact that you are not reaching certain milestones
表明我们大多数人实际上并没有走在一条常规的道路上。在某一个领域或其他领域，我们本能地非常担心自己没有达到规范。这是一种非常共同的经历，一种对我们所有人来说都很相似的感觉。这些可以说是我认为的里程碑焦虑的最大指标或迹象。如果你听到这里，觉得：“这听起来和我一直在经历的、和我一直有的感觉非常非常相似。”我希望你花一秒钟听听这些，因为如果你在其中认出了自己，那么里程碑焦虑可能正是你一直在苦苦挣扎的问题。首先，如果你一直在反刍这样一个事实：你没有达到某些里程碑，
and attributing that to some personal failure that you have, I think that really requires some closer examination. Ruminating is sometimes normal. However, I think when we are worrying too much about the future and whether or not something is going to go right for us, whether we're going to achieve a certain goal or milestone we have in mind, that can be really detrimental. Because the future is not always something we can control. So when we continue to think about it, all we do is experience that worry and anxiety more than once. The future is going to happen regardless of what's happening right now, regardless of what you're worried about, regardless of your milestone anxiety. But the second part of that is attributing it to some personal failure. I think back to that
并将其归咎于你自身的某种个人失败，我认为这真的需要更仔细地审视。反刍有时是正常的。然而，我认为当我们对未来以及某事是否会按计划进行、我们是否会实现心中某个特定的目标或里程碑担忧过多时，这可能非常具有破坏性。因为未来并不总是我们所能控制的。所以当我们继续去思考它时，我们所做的一切就是不止一次地经历那种担忧和焦虑。无论现在发生什么，无论你担心什么，无论你的里程碑焦虑如何，未来都会照常发生。但其中的第二部分是将其归咎于某种个人失败。我想起了那个
listener who wrote in, who was really worried that she hadn't had her first relationship yet. Often, instead of thinking about it objectively and reflecting on the fact that dating is really difficult, that your potential partners maybe weren't right for you, that taking your time, and being picky actually statistically does contribute to better long-term relationship outcomes. Instead, we look internally and we try to identify something that's wrong with us as the reason why we haven't met this milestone yet. This can really deeply injure our self-esteem and self-confidence, which further jeopardizes our ability to achieve the milestones and achieve what we deem as important. If you're looking inwards and contemplating the fact that you're a failure,
写信来的听众，她非常担心自己还没有经历过第一段恋爱。通常，我们不会客观地去思考并反思这样一个事实：约会真的很困难，你的潜在伴侣可能并不适合你，花时间去挑选其实在统计学上确实有助于带来更好的长期恋爱结果。相反，我们会向内审视，并试图找出我们自身存在的问题，以此作为我们尚未达到这个里程碑的原因。这可能会深深地损害我们的自尊和自信，从而进一步危及我们达成里程碑和实现我们认为重要的事情的能力。如果你向内审视并沉思这样一个事实：你是一个失败者，
contemplating some terrible thing about you, contemplating something that you're lacking, that's not healthy and it's also not true. There are a lot of things in your life that you can't control and it's not your fault if things don't turn out the way that you wanted them to. We may also feel a sense of failure that we are falling behind. We start seeing, those around us through a very narrow lens and only recognizing those who have what we don't have. It's called attention or selection bias. It's where our brains only select and pay attention to information that confirms our initial bias, resulting in that bias becoming more deeply ingrained.
沉思关于你自身的某种糟糕的事情，沉思你所缺乏的东西，这既不健康，也不是事实。你生活中有很多事情是你无法控制的，如果事情没有按你希望的那样发展，这不是你的错。我们可能也会感到一种失败感，觉得自己正在落后。我们开始通过一个非常狭隘的镜头来看待周围的人，并且只注意到那些拥有我们所没有的东西的人。这被称为注意力偏差或选择性偏差。这就是我们的大脑只选择和关注那些证实我们最初偏差的信息，从而导致这种偏差变得更加根深蒂固。
If we think that everyone around us has jobs that they love, everyone is buying houses, everyone is finding the people for them, we begin to only see instances in which that is true, resulting in us having a very skewed view of reality, which just serves to reinforce our anxiety. We may also experience a lot of internal pressure within and almost like a revolving carousel of repetitive, negative thoughts, such as, I should have graduated by now. what if I'm not married by 30? Why is everyone else buying property but me? What if I don't have kids?
如果我们认为我们周围的每个人都有他们热爱的工作、每个人都在买房、每个人都在找到适合自己的人，我们就会开始只看到那些情况属实的实例，从而导致我们对现实产生一种非常扭曲的看法，这只会起到强化我们焦虑的作用。我们内心也可能会经历大量的内部压力，几乎就像一个不断旋转的重复消极思想旋转木马，比如：“我早就该毕业了。”“如果我30岁还没结婚怎么办？”“为什么周围所有人都在买房，只有我没有？”“如果我没有孩子怎么办？”
And these thoughts are on rotation in our brain. This negative cycle can be very hard to break out of, especially when we account for some of the dialogue and rhetoric that may also be coming from our family and broader society. So if you find that when you sit with your thoughts, all you can think about is what you haven't done and the milestones you haven't achieved, it may be that milestone anxiety is the problem. It's the problem and the reason why you're feeling this way.
这些想法在我们的大脑中循环播放。这种消极的循环很难打破，特别是当我们考虑到可能也来自我们家庭和更广泛社会的某些对话和修辞时。因此，如果你发现当你静静地与自己的思想相处时，你所能想到的只有你没有做过的事情以及你没有达成的里程碑，那么里程碑焦虑可能就是那个问题所在。它就是问题所在，也是你为什么会有这种感觉的原因。
Other signs include things like excessive worry that other people are judging you, feeling hopeless symptoms of depression, and of course, generalized anxiety, such as fatigue, low motivation, trouble sleeping, muscle tension, irritability, nervousness, nausea, the whole package, all of those things. These physical symptoms, there's a reason why they occur. There's a reason why they arise. And it's because of a number of functions in our brains and our bodies that are designed to respond to threats. And feeling like we're falling behind or worrying about the future are interpreted by our brain as very real threats to our survival. Additionally, I think anxiety can be incredibly subjective and has many of its origins in our emotional cortexes.
其他迹象还包括：过度担心别人在评判你、感到绝望、抑郁症状，当然还有广泛性焦虑，例如疲劳、动力低下、睡眠困难、肌肉紧张、易怒、紧张、恶心，整套症状，所有这些东西。这些身体症状的出现是有原因的。它们之所以会出现是有原因的。这是因为我们大脑和身体中的许多功能旨在对威胁做出反应。而感觉自己正在落后或担心未来，被我们的大脑解释为对我们生存的非常真实的威胁。此外，我认为焦虑可以是极其主观的，其许多根源在于我们的情感皮层。
So when we magnify something and we continue to focus on how we're falling behind, our minds identify that this must be important for us to respond to. This is an important worry. So it elicits an anxiety response so that we pay attention. And it comes down to one tiny, little part of our brain called the amygdala. The amygdala is responsible for our fear response
因此，当我们放大某件事并继续关注我们是如何落后时，我们的大脑就会确定这一定是一件对我们很重要的、需要做出反应的事情。这是一个重要的担忧。因此，它会引发焦虑反应，以便我们集中注意力。这归结为我们大脑中一个极其微小的小部分，叫做杏仁核。杏仁核负责我们的恐惧反应，
and it's hypersensitive to perceived or real threats. Perceived threats being things like milestone anxiety. So it generates an alarm response. When it evaluates that a situation or an experience is threatening and what happens after that is
并且它对感知到的或真实的威胁高度敏感。感知到的威胁就是像里程碑焦虑这样的事情。因此，当它评估某个情况或经历具有威胁性时，它就会发出警报响应，而在那之后发生的是
the release of a bunch of neurotransmitters and neurochemicals that prepare our body to fight against this negative experience, resulting in what we know as anxiety. But that anxiety is often misplaced as we know, and milestone anxiety is an example of how our amygdala can do more harm than good when it falsely interprets a situation or a fear as dangerous. If you don't get married by a certain age, you are not in any danger. Nothing bad is going to happen. If you don't graduate on time, or your first job isn't all that it's cracked up to be, you're not going to drop dead.
释放出一堆神经递质和神经化学物质，让我们的身体准备好去对抗这种消极体验，从而导致我们所知的焦虑。但正如我们所知，这种焦虑经常被错置，而里程碑焦虑就是一个例子：当我们的杏仁核错误地将某种情况或恐惧解释为危险时，它带来的坏处就会大于好处。如果你在某个年龄没有结婚，你并没有处于任何危险之中。不会发生任何糟糕的事情。如果你没有按时毕业，或者你的第一份工作并非如你想象的那样美好，你也不会突然暴毙。
Things can go wrong in life and we can stray, of course, but it doesn't mean that we're unsafe. It doesn't mean that we're a failure. It just means that we are experiencing life differently and that's really nothing to be afraid of. In fact, I think it's rather beautiful to go about life in a way that is different and unique. Interestingly, I just want to put this point in here. Studies have also suggested that men and women experience milestone anxiety very differently. It didn't surprise me that women are much more likely to suffer this form of anxiety compared to men, and with greater severity, although men report feeling greater external pressure to meet certain milestones,
生活可能会出差错，我们当然也可能会偏离正轨，但这并不意味着我们不安全。这并不意味着我们是个失败者。这只是意味着我们正在以一种不同的方式体验生活，而这真的没有什么好害怕的。事实上，我认为以一种不同且独特的方式去经历生活其实相当美妙。有趣的是，我只想在这里补充一点。研究还表明，男性和女性经历里程碑焦虑的方式截然不同。女性比男性更有可能遭受这种形式的焦虑，且严重程度更高，这并没有让我感到惊讶，尽管男性报告说他们感受到了更大的外部压力去达到某些里程碑，
whereas that pressure for women is often more internal. This makes a lot of sense to me when we consider how society treats men versus women, especially when it comes to things around dating, marriage and children. I've always thought that men seem to have a more relaxed timeline when it comes to these goals. And society gives them more time to figure these things out, whilst if a woman doesn't have kids or a long-term partner by 30, suddenly we are hearing terms around them being a spinster or a cat lady. There's a lot more stigma associated with a woman's choices compared to a man's,
而女性感受到的这种压力通常更多是内部的。当我们考虑到社会如何对待男性与女性时，这对我来说非常合乎情理，尤其是在约会、婚姻和孩子等问题上。我一直认为，在这些目标方面，男性似乎有着更放松的时间表。社会给予他们更多的时间去把这些事情搞清楚，然而如果一个女性在30岁时还没有孩子或长期的伴侣，我们突然就会听到诸如“老姑娘”或“猫夫人”之类的词汇。与男性的选择相比，女性的选择带有更多的污名化，
which perhaps explains while my state anxiety is felt a lot more amongst women, and I think this is a remnant from a set of beliefs and a time period that is no longer relevant in the modern day. Historically, women remained in the home, and people saw their only duty as marriage, childbirth and child rearing. There was no reason to have a career or to pursue further education. So by the age of 25, 26, most women were settled down and had children, and we still feel an immense pressure to meet this outdated mould,
这也许解释了为什么女性更能深切感受到里程碑焦虑，我认为这是不再适用于现代的一套信仰和时期遗留下来的残余。在历史上，女性留在家里，人们认为她们唯一的职责就是婚姻、生育和抚养孩子。没有理由去追求职业或继续深造。因此，到了25岁、26岁时，大多数女性都安定下来并有了孩子，我们仍然感受到巨大的压力去迎合这种过时的模具，
which I find so disheartening. Society's timeline does not have to be your time. line. You don't need to have everything figured out and all the boxes ticked by a certain age. You don't need to compare your journey to others and feel bad when you think you're falling short. Because the truth is that you're not. There is not one way of going about your goals and the milestones that you see is important. There's not one way of doing it. I always think about my grandma who didn't graduate until she was in her 60s or my mom who had children. in her late 30s and early 40s or my close friend. She didn't have her first relationship
我发现这太令人沮丧了。社会的时间表不必成为你的时间表。你不需要在某个特定的年龄把所有事情都弄清楚、把所有的方框都打勾。你不需要将自己的旅程与他人进行比较，并在你认为自己有所不足时感到难过。因为事实是，你并没有不足。通往你的目标以及你认为重要的里程碑并没有唯一的一种方式。没有唯一的一种做事方式。我总是想起我的外祖母，她直到60多岁才大学毕业；或者我的妈妈，她在30岁末40岁初才生孩子；或者我的好朋友。她直到
till she was like 26 and I remember her telling me I feel so stressed that everyone around me is doing this what is wrong with me? And that anxiety is so unpleasant. It's so uncomfortable. But I want to talk about how we can be liberated from this and how we can combat milestone and anxiety and feel free to set our own timelines and agenda for life and not feel guilty or like a failure if things don't go according to plan. So all of that and more in just a second. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health
大约26岁才有了第一段恋爱，我记得她告诉我：“我感到压力太大了，周围的所有人都在这么做，我到底怎么了？”那种焦虑是如此令人不快。如此令人不适。但我想谈谈我们如何才能从中得到解放，如何才能对抗里程碑焦虑，并感到自由地去设定我们自己的人生时间表和议程，并且如果事情没有按计划进行，也不会感到内疚或觉得自己是个失败者。所有这些以及更多内容，马上回来。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中，如何建立心理坚韧、保持健康以及培养韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，
and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
去超越那些主导着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端蜕变成一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即“TWO%”，可在I-Heart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。
Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English.
你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMAs上摸了小金（Lil' Kim）的胸两下吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时？我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？嗯，你可以在《Look Back at it》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
每一集，我们都会在这里挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着去理解我们是怎么熬过来的。其中还包括最近的一集，马克·拉蒙特·希尔大谈80年代的快克可卡因。坦白说，84年对我很重要，不只是因为快克。我随时都能聊聊快克，不过就是让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二集讨论快克了。所以我开始看出一条贯穿始终的主线了。我们现在还要讨论艾滋病。谢谢你把话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests.
是的。我觉得对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我而言，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。快去iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了响应心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与许多优秀嘉宾的对话。
I'm talking Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid?
我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时我们在追求某样东西时，会深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们却还在追逐。并且我们不知道什么时候才算做够了。因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了一场场胜负的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在这个世界上当个好人很重要。你是个好人是因为你害怕吗？
Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring
因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。完全正确。那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真的能做一个好人。人。加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是基尔·盖恩斯，我们将在这里就疗愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hard Way》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一起亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了令人震惊的
inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You've We doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
她故事中的前后矛盾。这开启了长达数年的法律之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能看到他们的税款被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。
Greg Alespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at
格雷格·阿莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，突发新闻
Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There is no doubt that milestone anxiety is uncomfortable, especially when we begin to internalize and think that reflects something that is wrong with us. I think a lot of us hate relinquishing control and we like to believe that we can orchestrate what happens in our lives, which is often untrue. You know, I keep coming back
马里科帕县宣布劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事不会结束。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trap》播客。毫无疑问，人生阶段焦虑是令人不安的，尤其是当我们开始内化并认为这反映出我们自身出了什么问题时。我想我们很多人都讨厌放弃控制权，我们喜欢相信我们可以主宰生活中发生的事情，而这往往是不符合现实的。你知道，我一直在回想
to that dating conundrum we posed at the beginning, but I do think it's such a powerful anecdote to reflect on here. We cannot force love. We cannot force a healthy relationship. Sometimes the things that are most important to us, the milestones that are most important to us are beyond our control. And that can be really scary, especially when we think that everyone else seems to be in the fast lane towards achieving certain things. But life is really weird and it's unpredictable. Your friends may be getting engaged now, but five years down the line, that marriage may break apart and they're back to square one. You could have everything that you've ever wanted career-wise at 25. and then realize that you're deeply unhappy and make a huge change.
我们一开始提出的那个约会难题，但我确实认为这是一个非常有力、值得反思的轶事。我们无法强求爱情。我们无法强求一段健康的感情。有时对我们最重要的事情、对我们最重要的里程碑是超出我们控制的。这真的很吓人，尤其是当我们觉得其他人似乎都在快车道上实现了某些事情的时候。但生活真的很奇怪，而且是不可预测的。你的朋友现在可能订婚了，但五年后，那段婚姻可能会破裂，他们又回到了原点。你在25岁时可能拥有职业上想要的一切。然后意识到自己极不快乐并做出了巨大的改变。
But sometimes milestone anxiety stops us from seeing this clearly. It causes us to self-sabotage and it skews our reality so that we always feel behind. I want to talk about how we can address that now. First of all, you need to deep dive and look into and understand where this pressure is coming from in order to navigate the feelings that it brings up. Is it because you're facing a lot of pressure from your family to get married? Is it cultural? Is it religious? Is it because you had a very strict upbringing and your family was a very nuclear family who set a certain agenda and had these priorities about how life should turn out?
但有时人生阶段焦虑会阻止我们看清这一点。它会导致我们自我破坏，并扭曲我们的现实，让我们总是觉得自己落后了。我现在想谈谈我们该如何解决这个问题。首先，你需要深入挖掘、审视并理解这种压力的来源，以便应对它所带来的情绪。是因为你面临来自家庭的很大结婚压力吗？是文化原因吗？是宗教原因吗？是因为你有着非常严格的家教，你的家庭是一个核心家庭，他们设定了某种议程，并对生活应该如何发展有这些优先事项吗？
Are you reflecting on that and putting pressure on yourself to meet that mold? Is it because of social comparison? Are you looking outwards and seeing all these people in your life doing things that you wish you were doing? you need to know where the starting point is in order to get to the finish line, right? You need to understand why you are feeling this way, otherwise you're going to go in blind. Secondly, and this is advice, this is a suggestion that I give all the time. You need to be excited by the feeling that anxiety gives you. I'm going to explain that a little bit more because I think a lot of people often question this argument and this idea.
你在反思这一点并给自己施加压力去符合那个模子吗？是因为社会比较吗？你是不是向外看，看到你生活中的所有人都在做你希望自己也能做的事情？你需要知道起点在哪里才能到达终点，对吧？你需要明白自己为什么会有这种感觉，否则你就会盲目前行。其次，这是一个建议，也是我一直给出的一个建议。你需要对焦虑带给你的感觉感到兴奋。我将对此作更多解释，因为我认为很多人经常质疑这个论点和这个想法。
but anxiety and excitement, they feel very similar. They feel like a bit of nausea in our stomach. They feel like jitters. They feel like this energy in our body. They elicit the same feeling. So we can consciously change our interpretation of these shared sensations to tell ourselves that it is excitement rather than anxiety. Instead of fearing the future and what you have or have not done,
但焦虑和兴奋，它们的感觉非常相似。它们感觉像是胃里有点反胃。它们感觉像是紧张。它们感觉像是我们体内的能量。它们引发相同的感受。因此，我们可以有意识地改变对这些共同感觉的解释，告诉自己这是兴奋而不是焦虑。与其害怕未来以及你已经做过或没有做过的事情，
change your mindset to be excited by the possibilities. Once you address your negative cognitions and your thoughts, your outlook will also change. What if everything works out? We can be very pessimistic at times and get lost in the weeds, resulting in us constantly catastrophizing. And this is where we are always focused on the worst case scenario, that we will never achieve what we want, that we will never have children, that we will never have a partner, all of those worries swirl around in our mind.
不如改变心态，对各种可能性感到兴奋。一旦你解决了消极的认知和想法，你的视野也会发生改变。如果一切都顺利呢？有时我们可能会非常悲观，陷入细节中无法自拔，导致我们不断地将事情灾难化。这就是我们总是专注于最坏情况的地方，担心我们永远无法实现想要的目标，担心我们永远不会有孩子，担心我们永远不会有伴侣，所有这些担忧都在我们的脑海中盘旋。
So what you need to kind of change that mindset to is what if everything works out? This is exciting. I'm excited by the fact that there is so much freedom. I am excited by the flexibility. I'm excited by the possibilities. We also need to understand and really reflect and acknowledge on the fact that there is more than one way. of doing something. I think about this a lot when I think about having children. A lot of us assume that if we want kids, we need to have a partner first. And in some ways, that is still very much a socially
所以你需要将那种心态转变为：如果一切都顺利呢？这太令人兴奋了。我为有这么大的自由度感到兴奋。我为这种灵活性感到兴奋。我为各种可能性感到兴奋。我们还需要理解、真正反思并承认这样一个事实：实现目标的方法不止一种。
held belief. It's one that a lot of us assume, but that's not always the case. You can adapt. You are very capable of problem solving and finding a solution and a way through. If you want to have children, there are so many other options now, right? You can adopt, you can do surrogacy, you can do IVF with the sperm donor. There is so many other possibilities. So often what happens when we experience milestone anxiety is that we narrow our focus and think that there is only one way of being happy and one way of doing something. And that one way is that very traditional blueprint, you know, graduation, marriage, children, house, all of those things. But you don't need to do it that way. There have been so many people who have forged a new path and we have so many
每当我想起要孩子时，我经常会这样想。我们很多人都认为，如果我们想要孩子，我们首先需要一个伴侣。在某些方面，这仍然是一个根深蒂固的社会观念。这是我们许多人都认为理所当然的观念，但事实并非总是如此。你可以适应。你完全有能力解决问题、寻找出路并渡过难关。如果你想生孩子，现在还有很多其他的选择，对吧？你可以领养，你可以找代孕，你可以用精子捐赠做试管婴儿。还有很多其他的可能性。通常情况下，当我们经历人生阶段焦虑时，我们的视线会变窄，认为快乐只有一种方式，做某事也只有一种方式。而那唯一的方式就是非常传统的蓝图，你知道的，毕业、结婚、生孩子、买房子，所有这些事情。但你不需要那样做。有那么多人都开辟了新的道路，我们现在有这么多的
options now so that if there is something that you really want, you don't have to be held back by the fact that the most traditional way is the best way. You also need to embrace your authenticity. I know that sounds very much easier said than done, very wishy-washy, but sometimes our milestone anxiety is actually interlinked with low self-esteem and a fear of living authentically. We hide behind convention and tradition because we're worried that we will be rejected if we choose to take the road less traveled. Let that sink in for a little bit. Often, the reason why we are so aligned to this traditional way of doing things is because we are worried that we'll be judged if we don't do it that way. If we don't get married and decide to have
选择，所以如果有什么是你真正想要的，你就不必因为最传统的方式就是最好的方式而被束缚。你还需要拥抱你的真实自我。我知道这听起来知易行难，非常空洞，但有时我们的人生阶段焦虑实际上与低自尊和对真实生活的恐惧息息相关。我们躲在习俗和传统后面，因为我们担心如果我们选择走那条少有人走的路就会被拒绝。让这个想法在脑海中停留一会儿。通常，我们如此执着于这种传统的做事方式，是因为我们担心如果不那样做就会受到评判。如果我们不结婚，决定独自生
children on our own, if we don't get the perfect nine to five to career and decide to go out and do a side hustle. But authenticity is really your superpower. Choosing to do something the way that you want to do it in your own creative, unique way is something that is highly, highly admirable in my eyes. And how many people do we admire who have forged their own path? Think about, all of our heroes. People like Steve Jobs, like Dolly Parton, like Taylor Swift, all of these incredible people who are highly successful, they didn't get to where they are by following the mold and the conventional path. They pushed back against what society said they should have achieved by when. They pushed back against convention. And that always makes me feel
孩子，如果我们不找一份完美的朝九晚五的职业，而是决定出去搞副业。但真实自我确实是你的超级英雄。选择以你自己的创意、独特的方式去做你想做的事，在我看来是一件非常、非常令人钦佩的事情。我们有多少人钦佩那些开辟自己道路的人呢？想想吧，我们所有的英雄。像史蒂夫·乔布斯、多莉·帕顿、泰勒·斯威夫特，所有这些非常成功了不起的人，他们并不是通过遵循模版和传统道路才走到今天的。他们打破了社会关于应该在什么时候达成什么成就的规定。他们反抗传统。这总是让我感到
very comforted and a lot less alone, knowing that there are people who, you know, that there are people who have done this before me and knowing that sometimes the normal, quote unquote, normal way of doing things doesn't always lead to the greatest outcome or the best version of you. I think we also need to understand our relationship to social comparison. If you are experiencing milestone anxiety, if it's a massive stressor in your life, this often derives from our inherent tendency to view what others are doing and hold ourselves to that standard and thereby we impress a level of self-judgment that doesn't need to occur, that isn't healthy. You need to understand and I think really focus on your relationship to
非常安慰，也让我不再那么孤单，因为我知道有人，你知道的，有人在我之前就已经这样做了，而且我知道有时所谓正常、加引号的正常做事方式并不总是能带来最好的结果或最好的你自己。我认为我们还需要了解我们与社会比较的关系。如果你正在经历人生阶段焦虑，如果它是你生活中的一个巨大压力源，这通常源于我们天生倾向于去观察别人在做什么，并以此标准要求自己，从而给自己施加了一种不必要的、不健康的自我评判。你需要了解，我认为真正应该专注于你与
comparing yourself with other people. A big source of that is social media. It is very easy, and I don't need to say this, but I feel like I kind of want to, I want to reinforce this idea that it is very, very easy for people to display a perfect version of their lives on social media. And now we even have things like LinkedIn, where you can almost brag and be very performative in terms of your career. I don't think that's particularly healthy, but it is a reality of life that there are more points than ever to compare how your path in life compares to others. and when that becomes negative and toxic when we are doing it regularly, often that can be a massive trigger for milestone anxiety. So I did a whole episode on this on social comparison. Go back and listen to that. Go back and listen to how we can stop comparing ourselves to
将自己与他人进行比较的关系。其中的一个主要来源就是社交媒体。这非常容易，我其实不用说这个，但我感觉我还是想说，我想强化这个观点，那就是人们在社交媒体上展示他们生活的完美版本是非常、非常容易的。现在我们甚至还有像领英这样的平台，你几乎可以在上面吹嘘，并在职业生涯方面表现得很爱秀。我认为这并不是特别健康，但这是一个生活现实：比以往任何时候都有更多的点来比较你的人生轨迹与别人的差距。而当这种比较变得消极和有毒、当我们经常这样做时，这往往会成为人生阶段焦虑的巨大导火索。所以我围绕社会比较做了一整集节目。回去听听那一集吧。回去听听我们如何才能停止将自己与
others because I do think that it's an amazing way to kind of prevent milestone anxiety and to put us back on our truth path and make us feel comfortable with the way we're doing things. another tip is just to focus on what you have achieved. We can be really, really negative and mean towards ourselves. We can be really hard on ourselves. And often what that results in is kind of a self-inflicted blindness around the good things in life and our successes. There are people who are probably looking at you wishing that they had what you had, wishing that they had hit certain milestones that you've already hit.
他人进行比较，因为我确实认为这是一个极好的方法，可以防止人生阶段焦虑，让我们回到真实的道路上，让我们对自己的做事方式感到舒适。另一个小建议是只关注你已经取得的成就。我们有时会对自己非常非常消极和苛刻。我们对自己可以很严苛。而这通常导致的结果是，我们对自己生活中的美好事物和成功产生了一种自我施加的盲目。有些人可能正看着你，希望能拥有你所拥有的，希望自己能达到你已经达到的某些里程碑。
It's all incredibly subjective. And that's important to remind ourselves at times. everyone like we like we saw has experienced milestone anxiety in some form or another so you are not alone you are not the only one who was experiencing this and your path is no better or no worse than anyone else's i think that you have to kind of look at the full picture and really sit back and be happy with the reality that life isn't always going to go according to plan but that doesn't mean that you're a failure. The traditional way of doing things, that is a remnant from a very, very outdated model of our reality that has been socially ingrained in us from childhood.
这一切都非常主观。适时提醒自己这一点很重要。每个人，正如我们所看到的，都经历过某种形式的人生阶段焦虑，所以你并不孤单，你不是唯一一个经历这种感觉的人，你的道路并不比任何人的更好或更坏。我认为你必须客观看待全貌，真正静下心来，接受生活并不总是按计划进行这一现实，并为此感到高兴，但这并不意味着你是个失败者。那种传统的做事方式，那是我们现实中一个非常、非常过时模式的残余，从小就在社会上根深蒂固地烙印在我们心中。
You don't need to have a partner by 25 in order to be happy in the future. You don't need to have kids by a certain age. Those milestones are all constructed. They're all imagined. And you are very much free to be your own person and to do things in your own time without the fear that you're a failure, without the fear that you are missing out, without the fear that somehow by not doing things conventionally, you're never going to be happy because that's not the case. I really don't think that's the case, but our brains can make it such a huge point of fear and such a huge point of anxiety. So if you're going to take one thing away from this episode, It's that society's timeline does not have to be your timeline.
你不需要在25岁前找个伴侣才能在未来获得幸福。你不需要在某个年龄前生孩子。那些人生阶段都是被构建出来的。它们全都是想象出来的。你完全有自由去做你自己，在自己的时间里做事情，而不用担心自己是个失败者，不用担心自己错过了什么，不用担心如果不按常规行事，你就永远不会快乐，因为事实并非如此。我真的不认为事实如此，但我们的大脑会让这变成一个巨大的恐惧点和巨大的焦虑点。所以如果你要从这一集里带走一个观点，那就是社会的节奏不一定非要成为你的节奏。
You can do things at your own pace and still be a happy, amazing, intricate, beautiful human. So I really hope that that leaves you with a sense of positivity and a sense of happiness and security around your future, especially to that amazing person who wrote in. But I'm sure her story is one that is very shared and one that a lot of us feel very much attached to and very similar to. There's something in all of our lives that we feel like we're missing out on
你可以按照自己的节奏生活，依然可以成为一个快乐、惊艳、复杂、美丽的人。所以我真的希望这能给你带来一种积极的心态，以及对未来的一种快乐和安全感，特别是给那位写信的了不起的人。但我确信她的故事也是一个很多人都有共鸣、很多人都感到非常亲近和相似的故事。在我们所有人的生活中，总有一些事情让我们觉得自己错过了，
and we feel like that we're not doing at the pace that others around us are doing. So this is just your reminder to slow down, take life easy, and to treat anxiety the way that it's supposed to be treated as just a reaction, just a response, it's not the truth. But anyways, I really hope that you enjoyed this episode. I really did. I needed to hear this stuff. You're not alone. You know, when I was looking into this and all the psychology and the science, it brought me such a sense of solace and such a sense of peace that I'm not alone in experiencing these things. So I really do hope that you got something out of this, that you found it important. If there is someone in your life who needs to hear this, there is a friend who is worried about these things. You should send them. this episode. It might help them out. Or don't, that's all right. You can gatekeep it if you'd like to. And if you have any suggestions for further episodes, if you'd like me to expand on this topic in some
并且觉得我们的节奏没有周围的人快。所以这只是提醒你放慢脚步，轻松对待生活，并把焦虑当作它原本应该被对待的方式——只是一种反应，只是一种回应，它不是事实。不管怎样，我真的希望你喜欢这一集。我真的是这样。我太需要听到这些内容了。你并不孤单。你知道，当我深入研究这些内容以及所有的心理学和科学时，它给了我一种莫大的慰藉和平静，让我知道在经历这些事情时我并不孤单。所以我真的希望你从中有所收获，觉得它很重要。如果你的生活中有人需要听到这些，有哪个朋友正为这些事情担忧。你应该把这一集发给她。这可能会帮到他们。或者不发也行，也没关系。如果你愿意，你可以把它当成你的专属秘密。如果你对以后的节目有什么建议，如果你想让我以某种形式
form or another, please feel free to follow me at that psychology podcast and let me know your thoughts. Let me know your suggestions. I love hearing what everyone else is going through, what I think is relevant and universal for those of us in our 20s. I think, as always, it's such a valuable decade and we really do need to make the psychology and the science around it more accessible. So thank you for listening along. As always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts or Spotify wherever you are listening right now. I read every single review that is left.
进一步拓展这个话题，请随时在That Psychology Podcast关注我并让我知道你的想法。告诉我你的建议。我喜欢听每个人都在经历什么，以及我认为对于我们二十多岁的人来说什么是相关且具有普遍性的。我认为，一如既往，这是如此宝贵的一个十年，我们确实需要让围绕它的心理学和科学更加平易近人。谢谢大家的收听。一如既往，如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在苹果播客、Spotify或你现在收听节目的任何地方留下五星好评。我阅读留下的每一条评论。
Whenever I'm having a hard day, I go and read them. So I just want to thank you for all of the support. And as always, we will be back on Tuesday with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
每当我度过艰难的一天时，我就会去读它们。所以我只想感谢你们所有的支持。一如既往，我们将在周二带着另一集回归。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用的情况下选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在 我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、健身和建立抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难险阻，你就会浴火重生，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。
Listen to 2%. That's TWO.% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you do. your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam Jay. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we
收听《2%》。即TWO.%，可在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你收听播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·杰伊。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试着去理解我们是如何
survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to Look Back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever You get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起熬过来的。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代那样。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我觉得对黑人来说没有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host, Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to,
你正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行一些在其他任何地方都实在不安全去进行的坦诚对话，但在这里你是和一位知晓自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着你有这种能力，
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
就在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控让双胞胎怀孕。但这次怀孕似乎是个恶作剧。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档iHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证真人。本集暂无评论。点击转写中的任何句子即可留下评论。